correspondiendo a los puntos de presión en el cuerpo humano.
Su superficie, como en la naturaleza, varía su funcionalidad
no mediante la adición de otro material u otro ensamblaje,
sino variando continuamente y delicadamente la propiedad material.
Pero ¿es la naturaleza ideal?
¿No hay partes en la naturaleza?
No me crié en un hogar judío religioso,
pero cuando era joven,
mi abuela me contaba historias de la Biblia hebrea,
y uno de ellas se me quedó y llegó a definir mucho de lo que me importa.
Como ella relata:
"En el tercer día de la Creación, Dios manda a la Tierra
hacer crecer un árbol frutal cargado de fruta".
Para ese primer árbol frutal, no habría ninguna diferencia
entre tronco, ramas, hojas y frutos.
Todo el árbol era una fruta.
En cambio, la tierra hizo crecer árboles con ramas, corteza, tallos y flores.
La tierra creó un mundo hecho de partes.
A menudo me pregunto,
"¿Cuál sería el diseño si los objetos se hicieran de una sola pieza?
¿Volveríamos a un mejor estado de la creación? "
Así que buscamos que el material bíblico,
el tipo de material del árbol frutal con frutas, y lo encontramos.
El segundo biopolímero más abundante en el planeta se llama quitina,
y unos 100 millones de toneladas se producen cada año
por organismos como camarones, cangrejos, escorpiones y mariposas.
Pensamos que si podíamos sintonizar sus propiedades,
podríamos generar estructuras multifuncionales
en una sola pieza.
Así que eso es lo que hicimos.
Lo llamamos marisco legal.
(Risas)
Pedimos un montón de cáscaras de camarón,
las molimos y produjimos pasta de quitosano.
Variando las concentraciones químicas,
hemos podido lograr una amplia gama de propiedades,
desde oscuro, duro y opaco,
a la luz, suave y transparente.
Para imprimir las estructuras a gran escala, se construyó
un sistema con múltiples boquillas de extrusión controlado robóticamente.
El robot podía variar las propiedades del material sobre la marcha
y crear estas estructuras hechas de un solo material
3.5 m de largo, 100 % reciclable.
Cuando las piezas están listas, se las deja secar
para encontrar una forma natural al contacto con el aire.
Así que ¿por qué seguimos diseñando con plástico?
Las burbujas de aire que eran un subproducto del proceso de impresión
se utilizaron para contener microorganismos fotosintéticos
que aparecieron por primera vez en el planeta hace 3.5 mil millones años,
como escuchamos ayer.
Junto con nuestros colaboradores en Harvard y el MIT,
incrustamos las bacterias diseñadas genéticamente
para capturar rápidamente carbono de la atmósfera
y convertirlo en azúcar.
Por primera vez,
hemos podido generar estructuras que hacen su transición sin problemas
de viga a malla,
y si se amplía aún más, a ventanas.
Un árbol frutal cargado de fruta.
Trabajar con un material antiguo,
una de las primeras formas de vida en el planeta,
con abundante agua y con un poco de biología sintética,
hemos transformado una estructura hecha de cáscaras de camarón
en una arquitectura que se comporta como un árbol.
Y aquí está la mejor parte:
para objetos diseñados para biodegradarse,
puestos en el mar, alimentarán la vida marina;
y colocados en el suelo, ayudarán a crecer un árbol.
El ajuste para nuestra próxima exploración utilizando los mismos principios de diseño
era el sistema solar.
Buscamos la posibilidad de crear ropa para mantener la vida
para los viajes interplanetarios.
Para hacer eso, debemos dominar las bacterias y controlar su flujo.
Así como la tabla periódica, hicimos nuestra propia mesa de elementos:
nuevas formas de vida creadas computacionalmente,
fabricadas de forma aditiva
y aumentadas de forma biológica.
Me gusta pensar en la biología sintética como la alquimia líquida,
solo que en vez de transmutar metales preciosos,
se sintetizan nuevas funcionalidades biológicas dentro de canales muy pequeños.
Este campo se denomina microfluídica.
Imprimimos nuestros propios canales 3D para controlar el flujo
de estos cultivos bacterianos líquidos.
En nuestra primera pieza de ropa, se combinaron dos microorganismos.
El primero es la cianobacteria.
Vive en nuestros océanos y en los estanques de agua dulce.
Y el segundo, E. coli, la bacteria que habita en el intestino humano.
Una convierte la luz en azúcar, la otra consume azúcar
y produce biocombustibles útiles para el entorno construido.
Pero estos dos microorganismos no interactúan en la naturaleza.
De hecho, nunca se conocieron.
Ellos están aquí, diseñados por primera vez,
para tener una relación en una pieza de ropa.
Piense en ello como evolución, no por selección natural,
sino evolución por diseño.
Para contener estas relaciones,
hemos creado un único canal que se asemeja al tracto digestivo,
que ayudará a que fluyan estas bacterias y a que alteren su función de camino.
Entonces comenzamos hacer crecer esos canales en el cuerpo humano,
variando las propiedades del material según la funcionalidad deseada.
Si queríamos más fotosíntesis, diseñábamos canales más transparentes.
Este sistema digestivo portable, cuando se estira de un extremo a otro,
abarca 60 metros.
Esta es la mitad de la longitud de un campo de fútbol,
y 10 veces más que nuestro intestino delgado.
Y aquí está, como primicia en TED,
nuestra primera fotosintética portable,
canales líquidos brillantes con vida dentro de la ropa.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Mary Shelley dijo: "Somos criaturas pasadas de moda, solo la mitad está hecha."
¿Qué pasa si el diseño proporcionara la otra mitad?
¿Y si pudiéramos crear estructuras que aumentan la materia viva?
¿Y si pudiéramos crear microbiomas personales
que escanearan nuestra piel, repararan el tejido dañado
y sostuvieran nuestros cuerpos?
Piense en esto como una forma de editar la biología.
Toda esta colección "Trotamundos" lleva el nombre de los planetas,
no era para mí muy moderna en sí,
pero brindó la oportunidad de especular sobre el futuro
de nuestra raza en nuestro planeta y más allá,
combinar una visión científica con un montón de misterio
y alejarse de la edad de la máquina
hacia a una nueva era de la simbiosis entre nuestros cuerpos,
los microorganismos que habitamos,
nuestros productos e, incluso, nuestros edificios.
Yo llamo a esto la ecología material.
Para ello, siempre hay que volver a la naturaleza.
Por ahora, se sabe que una impresora 3D imprime material en capas.
También se sabe que la naturaleza no lo hace así.
Crece. Añade con sofisticación.
Este capullo del gusano, por ejemplo,
crea una arquitectura altamente sofisticada,
un hogar dentro del cual se metamorfosiza.
La fabricación no aditiva se acerca a este nivel de sofisticación.
Lo hace mediante la combinación no de dos materiales,
sino de dos proteínas en diferentes concentraciones.
Una actúa como estructura, la otra es el pegamento o la matriz,
uniendo esas fibras entre sí.
Y esto sucede a través de escalas.
El gusano de seda primero se prende en el medio ambiente,
crea una estructura de tensión,
y luego comienza a hilar un capullo de compresión.
La tensión y la compresión, las dos fuerzas de la vida,
se manifiestan en un único material.
Con el fin de comprender mejor cómo funciona este proceso complejo,
pegamos un imán pequeño
a la cabeza de un gusano de seda, a la hilera.
Lo colocamos dentro de una caja con sensores magnéticos,
y eso nos permitió crear esta nube de puntos en 3 dimensiones
y visualizar la compleja arquitectura del capullo del gusano de seda.
Sin embargo, al colocar el gusano de seda en un parche plano,
no dentro de una caja,
nos dimos cuenta de que hilaría un capullo plano
y todavía metamorforsizar sanamente.
Así que empezamos a diseñar diferentes entornos, diferentes andamios,
y hemos descubierto que la forma, la composición,
la estructura del capullo, se transmitía directamente por el medio ambiente.
A menudo se hierven los gusanos de seda hasta la muerte dentro de sus capullos,
su seda se deshace y se utiliza en la industria textil.
Vimos que diseñando estas plantillas podíamos dar forma a la seda cruda
sin hervir un solo capullo.
(Aplausos)
Se metamorfosizarían sanamente,
y podríamos crear estas cosas.
Así escalamos este proceso hasta la escala arquitectónica.
Tuvimos un robot hilador haciendo plantillas de seda,
y nos colocamos en nuestro sitio.
Sabíamos que los gusanos de seda emigrado hacia zonas más oscuras y frías,
por eso utilizamos un diagrama de ruta solar para revelar la distribución
de la luz y el calor en nuestra estructura.
Entonces creamos agujeros o aberturas,
para bloquear los rayos de la luz y el calor,
distribuyendo los gusanos de seda sobre la estructura.
Estábamos preparados para recibir a las orugas.
Pedimos 6500 gusanos de seda a una granja de seda en línea.
Y después de alimentarlos 4 semanas, estaban preparados a hilar con nosotros.
Las colocamos cuidadosamente en el borde inferior del andamio,
y mientras hilaban, crisalizaban, se apareaban, ponían huevos,
y la vida comienza de nuevo, como nosotros, pero mucho, mucho más corta.
Bucky Fuller dijo que la tensión es la gran integridad,
y tenía razón.
Al hilar seda biológica sobre la seda hilada robóticamente,
dan todo este pabellón su integridad.
Y en poco más de dos o tres semanas,
6500 gusanos de seda tejen 6500 km.
En una curiosa simetría, ésta es también la longitud de la ruta de la seda.
Las polillas, después de la eclosión, producen 1.5 millones de huevos.
Esto podría utilizarse para 250 pabellones adicionales en el futuro.
Así que aquí están las dos visiones del mundo.
Una hila seda mediante un brazo robótico,
la otra llena vacíos.
Si la última frontera del diseño es dar vida a los productos
y a los edificios que nos rodean,
para formar una ecología de dos materiales,
los diseñadores deben unir estas dos visiones del mundo.
Lo que nos lleva de vuelta, por supuesto, al principio.
Aquí está a una nueva era de diseño, una nueva era de la creación,
que nos lleva de un diseño inspirado en la naturaleza
a una naturaleza inspirada en el diseño,
que exige de nosotros, por primera vez,
que nos hagamos cargo de la naturaleza.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Muchas gracias. Gracias.